Okay, so we're back at the screen. We're
now going to look at generating
international trade ideas in individual
equities, like we did in the previous
video using the ISM, but now we're going
to be looking at ADRs, American Depository
Receipts, which are essentially
international companies, so non-domestic
U.S. companies.
So we're looking at companies outside the
United States with listings on U.S.
exchanges as ADRs. Now this video is going
to be relatively shorter than most videos
in the PTM video series, and that's
because this is really just an exercise in
organization, common sense, and
processing.
Now, if you recall, the macro dashboard,
essentially what we're doing here is we're
looking at the right-hand side now of the
macroeconomic leading indicator dashboard.
When it comes to American Depository
Receipts, so international companies with
U.S. dollar-denominated stock listings on
U.S. domestic exchanges, when it comes to
ADRs, there is a universe of ADRs.
At any one time, there's going to be a
certain amount of ADRs that are currently
listed on U.S. exchanges, and of course,
those stocks, those companies, will have
exposure to different geographies around
the world.
However, their ADR listings mean they
report in U.S. dollars, and similarly,
even U.S. companies that have
international exposure in their revenues
and earnings will have exposure to certain
international geographies outside the
United States.
So whether a company is listed in the U.S.
as an international ADR, denominated in
U.S. dollars, or it's a U.S. company with
international exposure, regardless, if a
company has international exposure,
we, of course, need to have resources to
enable us to appraise the international
exposure in establishing a portfolio bias.
So what we'll be doing in this video is
looking at this in the context of ADRs, so
not U.S. domestic companies with
international exposure, but the same
disciplines would apply.
So, for example, a German company has an
ADR listing, and they have large exposure
with their revenues and earnings in
Germany, maybe also in Italy, maybe also
across the rest of the European Union.
So, of course, we need to be on top of
German, Italian, and European
macroeconomics in order to have a
portfolio bias, a bias on German stocks
that have exposure, or companies that have
exposure predominantly to the German
economy, plus the Italian economy, and
even the wider European economy.
So if we are establishing a country bias,
and therefore potentially a stock bias, in
stocks that have exposure to certain
geographies, we need to be on top of a
number of things from a macro perspective.
So we want to be on top of our money
market indicators in that particular
geography, we want to be on top of any
surveys, and we also want to be on top of
international cyclical commodity prices,
and whether we're seeing demand-led or
supply-led price increases or decreases.
So, yes, we use our macroeconomic leading
indicator dashboard to get an overall
portfolio bias, but we do also use the
macro dashboard in getting a geographical
bias as well.
It can also be used for that.
And on top of that, it can also be used
for generating trade ideas in individual
equities, not only domestically in the
U.S., so for U.S.-listed domestic stocks,
but also for international ADRs.
So what we're going to focus on here,
because we've already covered
international surveys in Europe and China,
we're going to focus here on the IHS
market PMIs.
So on the macro dashboard, you'll see the
IHS market PMIs mentioned for Japan, U.K.,
Brazil, and Canada.
And there is actually, in fact, a market
PMI index for most countries.
Now, we also mentioned earlier in the
video series about these things called
American Depository Receipts, ADRs, when
we were actually discussing China.
What ADRs actually are, are essentially
secondary listings.
So it's companies that have their primary
listing in another country denominated in
the currency of that country.
And what a lot of companies actually do is
also choose to list equity in the U.S.
domestic market as American depository
receipts denominated in U.S. dollars.
And this is usually so institutional
investors in the U.S., so most
importantly, U.S. pension money, can
maintain custody holdings onshore.
So it's lower risk, and it's in, well,
denominated in U.S. dollars.
And it's a win-win for both sides, because
the pension funds, U.S. pension funds, get
to invest in these companies,
and the companies get to raise capital in
the United States.
Now, if you recall from earlier in the
video series, when we covered ADRs, when
looking at China, we covered them briefly
there.
ADRs can trade on exchange, and they can
trade off exchange, so over-the-counter
OTC.
What we're interested in, as traders and
portfolio managers, we're interested in
only the on-exchange ADRs,
so the ones that we can access and trade
on our brokerage platforms.
On top of that, many of these ADRs have
listed options also, but some don't, so we
always have to be aware of that.
It's basically a function of market
capitalization or size of the company and
the liquidity of the stock.
Now, up to this point, we've been looking
at a universe of around 2,200 stocks in
the U.S. domestically,
and what we can do when we start looking
internationally is we can increase our
opportunity set.
So we can use our international leading
indicators, and we can use the IHS market
PMIs and American depository receipts
to increase the opportunity set from 2,200
stocks to 2,600 stocks.
So at the time of recording, we're looking
at around 400 ADRs in terms of our ADR
opportunity set.
And of course, this will change in the
future.
There'll be more, there'll be less.
It doesn't really matter.
What you need to focus on here is the
actual process, and we're going to give
you all of the resources here to do that.
So when it comes to the market PMIs, we
can use them in exactly the same way as we
use the ISM PMIs inside the U.S.
However, the data for all of the countries
covered globally is very highly priced.
So IHS market is a company, and they do
sell this data.
Unfortunately, it's very, very highly
priced, costs a lot to purchase it up
front, and maintain all of the data on a
continual basis.
You would literally have to pay IHS
market, the company, hundreds of thousands
of dollars to get it.
And you'd be paying an annual subscription
per user for tens of thousands of dollars
on a continuous basis.
The company itself, IHS market, is
actually a public company, and the company
is registered in Bermuda.
But they do have a listing in the U.S.
And the data product that they sell for
PMIs is essentially aimed at institutional
traders, at investment banks and hedge
funds, and also investors.
So really, we're looking at long-only
asset managers and long-short portfolio
managers as their clients, not retail
traders.
So the price point for retail traders to
get hold of all of this data and manage it
on a continuous basis is just not viable.
However, non-institutional traders, like
retail traders, can still benefit from the
press releases.
And you can use this information in the
same way as we did for the ISM in the
previous video to take positions in ADRs
that are denominated in USD.
So we do have a download here that
accompanies this video.
So go to the downloads area and download
the spreadsheet ADRs list.
This is going to help you understand how
we actually process for individual ADR or
individual equities, trade ideas in ADRs,
utilizing macro data.
So this is just common sense processing.
But we've put this all together for you in
a template to create an opportunity set
for tradable ADRs at the time of making
the video.
At any point in the future, you would just
update this spreadsheet and use it as a
template and utilize the resources
mentioned in the video.
And of course, if resources change in the
future, then you yourself, you're going to
have to go and find other sources.
Concentrate on the process, guys.
It's the process that matters here.
So in putting the sheet together here, we
basically revisit the source for ADR
information that we referred to earlier in
the PTM video series.
So topforeignstocks.com, foreign ADRs
list.
And there, what you're going to find is on
exchange listed, so tradable ADRs, and
they're split up into geographical regions
first, then by country.
And within each country, you're going to
find ADRs that trade both as on exchange
and as OTC, over the counter.
And what you do here is you get a bit
dirty, get a bit naughty, and you scrape
the data from the website.
So all you do is select the data and cut
and paste it into a spreadsheet.
And this is what we've done for the
spreadsheet in the downloads area ADRs
list and organized it all properly.
So what we do here is we calculate the
opportunity set of foreign ADRs listed in
the U.S., and we organize the data
properly by sector.
So with the template and the download, all
the initial work has been done for you,
organizing the data in that spreadsheet.
However, on a continuous basis, you're
going to have to maintain the sheet
yourself, and generally speaking, you're
going to be updating it at least once,
possibly twice a year.
ADR listings don't change very frequently,
so you'll be infrequently updating this
spreadsheet.
So what do we find when we put this
spreadsheet together?
Well, there's 415 foreign ADRs at the time
of recording that are tradable.
So they're traded on exchange at the time
of recording this video, writing the
presentation on the screen.
If we look at the data by country, we can
see that the foreign ADR market is very
much dominated by China, mainland Europe,
and the U.K.,
making approximately combined 70% of all
ADRs in total.
And then when we look at China's
contribution to listed tradable ADRs,
China makes up around 37% of all ADRs.
So this is around half of the ADRs when we
add up China, Europe, and the U.K.
Now, what's more important to us is the
sector data.
We can't simply look at market data for a
particular country, then go into the ADR
market,
and then just go long or short a
particular stock because the macro data in
the country where a stock has its primary
listing was either good or bad.
So firstly, a company that has its primary
listing in a particular country may have
very small or even no exposure in their
revenues and earnings to that country.
And secondly, what's way more important
for us after we've established a country
bias or portfolio bias,
when we're considering bottom-up
fundamentals, and that's whether it's a
U.S. domestic stock or an international
stock,
is the actual fundamental performance of
the sector.
So we take the same approach here with
ADRs and international companies as we do
with all macro indicators.
At first, we establish a country or
portfolio bias, and then we look at
particular sectors based on the filter of
expected stock performance,
so volatility, that's based on growth,
x-growth, defensive characteristics, and
also EPS growth profiles.
And of course, like we always do, we do
further work on positive and negative
outliers and everything in between in the
sector.
Now, when we're processing and organizing
this data on a sector basis, we can rank
the largest opportunity sets.
So on a sector basis, the largest amount
of ADRs are characterized as pharma and
biotech,
so in the pharma and biotech industry.
And these are mostly untradeable defensive
stocks, and that makes up 15.42% of all
ADRs.
Next, making up just over 11% of all ADRs
are software and computer services stocks.
And 35 of those stocks out of 46 are
actually Chinese ADRs.
Next up is banks, and these make up 6% of
all ADRs.
And most of these are European and UK
banks, with some developed Asian banks in
Japan and Korea.
But there's a total of 25 banks at the
time of recording.
Next sector, after banks, is tech,
hardware, and equipment, which makes up
about 6%, again, of all ADRs.
And these stocks are dominated by European
companies and Taiwanese companies.
But there is a total of 24 ADRs in the
tech, hardware, and equipment sector.
After that comes the financial services
sector, which makes 5.3% of all ADRs.
And these are mostly Chinese ADRs, which
are very dominant in this particular
sector,
making up 18 of the 22 ADRs in the sector.
Next sector, we've got travel and leisure
stocks, travel and leisure ADRs, making up
4.34% of all ADRs.
And again, this is mostly Chinese ADRs,
covering airlines, hotels, and booking
sites,
which are actually split fairly evenly.
After that, we have marine transportation
stocks, making up, again, 4.34% of all
ADRs, totally dominated by Greek stocks.
So 17 of 18 of those stocks in marine
transportation are Greek shipping stocks.
Next in the sheet, we actually combined
two sectors, so industrial metals and
mining,
so hybrid companies, and more purer plays
in mining.
And this comes out as 4% of all ADRs.
And this sector is dominated by South
African stocks and Australian stocks.
But there's a total of 17 of these stocks.
So you can see how we go about things when
we're doing this.
We're systematically ranking our
opportunity set for ADRs based on sectors.
And we can actually go through each of
these sectors and characterize them
further
and make some interesting observations and
commentary in further detailing the actual
opportunities in each sector.
So let's start with the pharmaceutical and
biotech sector.
And from a trader and portfolio manager
perspective, especially for retail,
this is a very important sector to
discuss.
Not just in the context of ADRs, but also
in the wider context,
to include all pharma and biotech stocks
in the United States as well.
So in our ADR opportunity set,
pharmaceutical and biotech stocks,
even though it's the largest opportunity
set of any sector in the foreign ADRs
list,
and it does make up 64 stocks,
we actually don't recommend that you trade
them at least in your first year as a
retail trader,
and perhaps even longer.
And this would also go for US pharma and
biotech stocks as well.
Now, why is this?
Well, it's because it's probably the most
difficult sector in the entire stock
market
to actually have an edge in, even as a
professional trader.
When you look at the individuals and
organizations or institutional investors
and traders
that are involved in this sector at the
highest level,
so if we're looking at hedge funds and
investment banks,
they have teams of PhD biochemists as both
research analysts and portfolio managers
that have literally studied chemical
compounds for years.
And the way pharmaceutical and biotech
stocks work and how they're valued,
well, they have both current drug
portfolios,
so drugs that are being sold in the market
right now and making current sales,
and they have pipeline drugs,
so drugs that are not currently being
sold,
but they're going through the approval
process with the FDA.
So they're going through phase one, phase
two, and phase three approval with the
FDA.
Now, the fair value or NPV of these
companies' stock prices
is usually worked out on a per share basis
by adding the DCF, the discounted cash
flow model of the current portfolio,
together with a probability-adjusted DCF
of the pipeline portfolio,
and then we arrive at an NPV per share.
Now, splitting this up into current and
pipeline,
the current portfolio will include in
research analyst models
an assumption of when each drug reaches
peak sales
and when those drugs come off patent.
And in the pipeline portfolio, so drugs
that are not yet approved,
at different phases of the approval
process,
so phase one, phase two, and phase three,
at the FDA approval process for the
pipeline drugs,
what analysts do is they assign
probabilities of approval
that grow higher at each stage of the
clinical trials.
So, from a retail trader perspective,
I mean, there's pretty much no way that
you can have a real edge here
over many trades in this sector over a
long period of time,
unless, of course, you're a PhD biochemist
and an absolute finance whiz,
or you actually have inside information.
So, yes, the tradable ADR's opportunity
set
does increase our overall opportunity set
in the stock market.
However, when we get into the details of
the sectors themselves,
the biggest one, pharmaceutical and
biotech stocks,
is not very conducive over a long period
of time
for retail traders to actually have an
edge.
Certainly, in your first year of trading,
you should probably be avoiding both
pharmaceutical and biotech stocks
in ADRs, in the ADR universe,
and even US domestic listed stocks.
And I would say, after your first year,
as long as you're up and making quite a
lot of money,
at that stage, you will have earned the
right
to go and take positions
and in the pharmaceutical and biotech
sectors.
And as long as you're not betting the farm
and you're actually implementing sensible
risk management
with single stock percentage limits on
your portfolio,
where you don't actually have a large
amount of exposure
to one idea,
then yes, as long as you do have an edge
in a particular farmer or biotech stock,
then yes, you're essentially,
because you're making money at this stage
and making a good amount of money,
you're betting with the house's money.
But even at that stage,
you've got to really ask yourself the
question here,
do you really have an edge
in comparison to other sectors?
And is that capital really being
optimized?
Because remember,
that capital can go into something else
where you potentially
have a much better understanding
and a much better edge
in the idea.
So just bear in mind
that even after one year
where you're up and making good money,
there's always opportunity cost
for that capital
to go into other ideas.
So from a total opportunity set
perspective,
yes,
looking at increasing our opportunity set
by introducing ADRs
is a logical step.
However,
we've just got to be a bit careful
when we get into the details
of understanding
what the opportunities actually are.
And the pharmaceutical
and biotech sector
within ADRs
is a classic example of that.
Next up is
software and computer services stocks.
So here
in the ADR
opportunity set
in this sector,
Chinese ADRs
make up the vast majority here.
So they're making
making up 35
of the 46
software and computer services
ADRs.
And in this sector,
you can definitely
have positions
in these names.
So when you're actually
working within
the US
software
or computer services sector
and you're doing
your quantitative work,
you should repeat
the same analysis
for these stocks
and include them
when they are
direct comparables
or direct
competitors
to
US software
or computer services
stocks.
And what will happen is
you'll just get
a better understanding
of how the market
values
US stocks
in this sector
versus
Chinese stocks.
And of course,
as with any
trade idea generation
process that you go through,
you're going to then
graduate from the
quantitative
to the qualitative
phase.
And in your processes,
you take the same
approach
as you do
in US
listed
domestic stocks
with
international
ADRs.
When you do
further work
at any point
in time,
when you do
some further
digging,
you're going to
figure out
the reasons
why
a particular
stock in
China
trades,
for example,
at a premium
or a discount
to its direct
comparables
in the United
States.
So for this
sector,
software and
computer services,
we can definitely
take positions
here,
and we are
increasing
our opportunity
set overall
by bringing
these ADRs
into our
overall
opportunity
set.
Next up
is the
banks sector,
and most
bank ADRs,
as we saw
earlier,
are in Europe,
UK,
Japan,
Korea,
and also
there's banks
in Chile.
Now,
when we look
into this sector
and think of
what opportunities
it brings us,
what it adds
to our overall
opportunity set,
well,
when we look
at the sector
overall,
globally,
with the
exception of
some Chilean
banks,
the performance
of the retail
banking sector
globally over
the last 10
to 20 years
has been
pretty dismal.
And that's
really because
of the general
trend of lower
and lower
interest rates.
So as
interest rates
have kept
falling,
the net
interest
margin
at retail
banks
has
collapsed.
And a lot
of these
banks,
especially
in Europe,
operate
essentially
as zombie
banks.
Now,
again,
when you're
going through
your processes
here,
you can
compare
the comparable
bank valuations
versus U.S.
banks
when you're
working through
the sector
and when
looking for
the best
potential
longs
and
shorts.
However,
you have
to remember
to split
them up
properly
and
characterize
each bank
correctly.
So you've
got to
split them
into
investment
banks,
retail banks
and hybrids.
You need
to make
sure that
you're
comparing
apples to
apples
and pairs
to pairs
and not
apples to
pairs.
And what
you'll find
is that
comparable
retail bank
valuations
are going
to be
primarily
driven
by net
interest
margins
or
differentials
of net
interest
margins
and the
official
interest rate
and market
differential.
So when
you're in
this sector
in banks
in the
ADRs
just tread
carefully
and make
sure you're
processing
correctly
using as
much
common
sense
as
possible.
Next
sector
on the
list
is
tech
hardware
and
equipment
in
this
sector
most
of
the
ADRs
are
in
Europe
and
Taiwan.
In
Europe
the
main
stocks
are
semiconductor
stocks
so
they're
chip
manufacturers
with
cellular
or
mobile
handset
some
peripheral
manufacturers
and
also
some
small
3D
imaging
stocks
the
ADRs
from
Taiwan
are
totally
dominated
by
semiconductor
stocks
again
when you're
processing
so when
you're doing
the work
on the
US
sector
comparables
it's
essential
in your
processing
to include
these stocks
in your
analysis
because the
valuations
of these
companies
on an
absolute
basis
and relative
to each
other
the
valuation
really
matters
especially
in the
semiconductor
industry
but again
overall
bringing in
this sector
tech
hardware
and
equipment
from
ADRs
the
opportunity
set
in
ADRs
to our
overall
opportunity
set
is totally
feasible
you can
definitely
have
positions
in
international
tech
hardware
and
equipment
stocks
with
listed
ADRs
the
semi
stocks
the
semi
sector
is
highly
cyclical
and it's
very useful
for expressing
macro driven
long and
short trade
ideas
so by
bringing
this sector
into our
analysis
we are
definitely
increasing
our
overall
opportunity
set
next up
is
financial
services
and
Chinese
ADRs
if you
recall
make
up
of
the
ADRs
in
this
sector
the
types
of
stocks
that
you're
going
to
find
in
this
sector
you're
mostly
going
to
find
consumer
loans
businesses
mortgage
financing
providers
and
wealth
management
businesses
now it's
pretty
questionable
whether
these
stocks
actually
increase
our
overall
opportunity
set
why
because
it's
quite
difficult
to get
an edge
here
because
a lot
of the
market
caps
of these
stocks
are very
low
and
information
about
most of
these
companies
is very
hard to
come by
for retail
traders
so it's
not likely
that you're
going to get
many
opportunities
here
over
a long
period
of time
in this
sector
next up
is the
travel and
leisure
sector
and
seven
of the
travel and
leisure
ADRs
are
Chinese
again
across
the
board
however
of
those
stocks
there
is
a
mix
of
airlines
hotels
and
booking
websites
what
you'll
find
here
in
this
sector
with
ADRs
is
that
you'll
get
a lot
of
various
countries
low
cost
airlines
that
trade
as
ADRs
secondary
listings
in the
United
States
so again
there's
opportunities
there
this
is
a
highly
cyclical
sector
and
very
useful
for
doing
sector
work
and
sector
processing
for
valuation
comparisons
against
US
domestic
stocks
when
you're
pursuing
macro
driven
trade
ideas
so
the
travel
and
leisure
sector
does
increase
our
opportunity
set
next
up
is
the
marine
transportation
sector
and
basically
all of
these
ADRs
are
shipping
stocks
from
Greece
and
generally
they
have
very
low
market
caps
so
they're
not
great
stocks
for
shorts
however
where
there
are
opportunities
is
on
the
long
side
so
in
the
larger
market
cap
stocks
they
can
potentially
be
used
as
macro
driven
long
ideas
positions
especially
in
cyclical
upswings
and
lastly
our
final
sector
we
have
industrial
metals
and
mining
so
the
hybrids
plus
pure
mining
stocks
and
what
we've
done
here
is
just
combined
all
industrial
metals
and
mining
sectors
together
because
they're
very
closely
connected
and
highly
cyclical
when we
look into
the details
of the
sectors
in
industrial
metals
Chinese
ADRs
fall into
the commodity
groupings
of
aluminium
steel
and
concrete
European
ADRs
into
the
steel
category
South
Africa
has
the
most
mining
stocks
and
all
of
them
are
actually
gold
stocks
and
Europe
has
one
stock
that's
predominantly
a gold
miner
or gold
ADR
the
UK
and
Australia
has
two
large
diversified
global
mining
ADRs
in
BHP
Billiton
which is
Aus and
UK
and
Rio Tinto
which is
UK
so
gold
stocks
are
very
US
dollar
and
interest
rate
sensitive
and
can
be
compared
to
gold
stocks
in
terms
of
valuations
in
the
US
and
Canada
when
you're
doing
your
processing
so
in
the
gold
stocks
sector
gold
equities
we
are
definitely
increasing
our
opportunity
set
here
elsewhere
where
we're
increasing
our
opportunity
set
is
also
in
diversified
miners
the
large
cap
diversified
miners
in
particular
can
actually
become
useful
shorts
in
cyclical
downturns
and
can
also
be
compared
as
benchmarks
in
terms
of
valuation
to
mining
stocks
in
the
US
and
globally
so
we
do
overall
here
in
industrial
metals
and
mining
stocks
increase
our
opportunity
set
again
so
overall
guys
you just
got to
tread
carefully
when
you're
looking
at
ADOS
and
make
sure
you're
optimizing
your
opportunities
on a
sector
basis
so
what
you
essentially
have
to
do
here
with
ADOS
when
you're
processing
is
you
have
to
marry
up
the
macro
and
the
micro
previous
video
with
the
ISM
data
however
we
don't
get
data
at
the
macro
level
for
each
country
on
a
sector
basis
so
what
you
have
to
do
is
look
at
on
the
micro
level
company
valuations
for
ADOS
relative
to
the
United
States
and
also
look
at
the
geographical
distribution
for
revenue
and
earnings
where
it
matters
you'll
be
overlapping
the
macro
analysis
the
macro
data
with
your
micro
analysis
so
yes
we do
both
the
country
analysis
based on
market
PMIs
and we
overlap
that
with our
sector
analysis
and
stock
analysis
so
you've
just
got to
be
organized
at
both
the
country
level
and
the
sector
level
so
where
do
we
actually
go
and
get
the
country
data
well
as
mentioned
previously
in the
video
we
go
to
IHS
market
so
we
go
to
market
economics
PMIs
to
look
at
PMIs
for
all
countries
so
the
first
stop
home
page
here
is
to
look
for
the
PMI
calendar
so
if
you
click
through
to
that
you'll
get
taken
to
a
section
where
you've
got
calendar
and
PMI
releases
if
you
click
on
the
calendar
you'll
be
taken
to
a
page
where
you
have
all
upcoming
PMI
releases
for
each
country
so
all
very
straightforward
you
read
the
press
releases
and
you
figure
out
whether
the
manufacturing
and
service
sectors
are
actually
growing
slowing
or
contracting
in
those
countries
so
you'll
have
upcoming
releases
in
the
calendar
so
you
can
stay
on
top
of
those
and
you
also
have
the
past
releases
as
well
so
if
you
click
on
PMI
releases
all
of
the
most
recent
past
releases
are
going
to
come
up
and
going
back
further
they're
going
to
be
indexed
in
the
website
by
the
month
they
were
released
so
yes
what
you're
getting
here
in
most
cases
is
just
the
headline
data
and
in
some
cases
more
detailed
breakdown
and
some
commentary
but
overall
it's
useful
stuff
to
add
into
your
overall
macro
dashboard
and
then
marry
this
up
with
your
micro
work
so
let's
summarize
all of
this
when it
comes
to
market
data
and
ADRs
if we
look at
our
ADR
universe
and we
look at
what's
available
in terms
of
market
PMIs
globally
how is
this
helping
us
get
more
trade
ideas
how do
we
actually
utilize
market
PMIs
for
our
macro
driven
ADR
trade
ideas
well
a lot
of
these
trade
ideas
can
be
generated
by
simply
utilizing
the
market
data
in the
same
data
through
each
sector
for
ADRs
we
can
see
what
the
opportunities
actually
can
be
in
the
future
and
what
we
need
to
stay
on top
of
in
terms
of
macro
so
we're
going
to
stay
away
from
pharma
and
biotech
in
Chinese
software
and
computer
services
ADRs
these
are
cyclicals
and
their
potential
accounting
frauds
so
most
of
the
time
what
you're
going
to
be
doing
in
this
sector
is
probably
using
this
sector
in
ADRs
for
short
ideas
when
we
look
at
banks
we
look
at
Europe
UK
Japan
even
Chilean
this
sector
is
interest
rate
cycle
sensitive
relative
to
the
US
and
this
is
going
to
present
us
potential
long
and
short
ideas
when
we
look
in
the
travel
and
leisure
sector
for
ADRs
these
are
airlines
hotels
booking
sites
and
these
are
essentially
cyclical
proxies
on the
economy
and
we
can
get
both
long
and
short
ideas
here
for
the
Greek
shipping
stocks
these
are
highly
cyclical
low
market
cap
but
the
higher
market
cap
ones
can
provide
us
with
selective
longs
in
periods
of
expansion
in
industrial
metals
and
mining
so
for
South
African
and
European
gold
stocks
we've
got
US
dollar
and
interest
rate
proxies
there
so
we
can
use
that
sector
for
both
longs
and
shorts
for
the
mega
cap
diversified
mining
stocks
with
their
primary
listings
in
the
UK
and
Australia
we're
going
to
be
using
those
potentially
as
short
ideas
in
cyclical
downturns
and
then
for
all
other
ADRs
so
all
other
listed
ADRs
they're
just
useful
for
assessing
direct
comparable
valuations
versus
their
US
peers
now
remember
one trap
that you
don't want
to fall
into
here
is
looking
at
a
country's
PMIs
and
then
deducing
that
because
a
company
has
its
primary
listing
in
a
particular
country
then
readings
of
that
country's
PMI
is
significant
for
the
stock
case
if
the
company
is
a
global
player
so
for
example
with
the
UK
listed
mega
cap
mining
stocks
yes
they
have
their
primary
listing
in
the
UK
but
they
have
globally
diversified
revenues
now
you
will
notice
that
across
the
board
with
the
exception
of
the
pharmaceutical
and
biotech
sectors
that
the
ADR
universe
can be
characterized
as
mostly
cyclical
in
nature
and
also
mostly
what we
would
call
old
economy
stocks
so
in
banking
and
financial
services
industrial
metals
and
mining
tech
hardware
and
equipment
travel
and
leisure
shipping
so
it's
just
important
to
remember
that
we're
not
here
looking
at
what
we
would
term
new
economy
stocks
we're
predominantly
looking
at
old
economy
sectors
old
economy
stocks
now
we can
get
exposure
as
traders
to
both
positive
and
negative
cyclical
outliers
in the
US
however
it's
important
to
see
the
whole
picture
globally
by
including
these
stocks
in our
quant
analysis
once of
course
after
we've
established
a
country
bias
if it's
required
and
just
remember
country
biases
are not
necessary
if
a company
or their
stock
is a
global
operator
but if
it is
a
local
operator
where it
has a
very high
percentage
of
their
revenues
and
earnings
in a
particular
country
then a
bias
is
absolutely
necessary
okay guys
so this
brings us
now to
the end
of this
video
where we're
looking at
the ADR
universe
and generating
trade ideas
there from
market
PMIs
let's
head over
to the
desk
for a
recap
here
okay
so welcome
back to
the desk
guys
so the
last couple
of videos
we looked
at how
to generate
single stock
trade ideas
utilising
macroeconomic
indicators
and in the
first video
we looked
at how
we do it
in the US
and then in the
second video
how we
actually go
about that
process
internationally
so as
you can
see what
it really
comes down
to is
just being
very organised
using a
lot of
common sense
and engaging
in many
of the
processes
that we've
actually seen
as core
processes
in previous
parts of
the PTM
video series
so in
the US
we looked
at the
example
of the
ISM
manufacturing
data
but we
can also
look at
sector
data
in the
service
sector
as well
in the
non-manufacturing
report on
business
we can
also look
at for
example
the
UMCSI
University
of Michigan
Consumer
Sentiment
Index
and we
can look
for straight
consumer
plays
in single
stocks
we can
also look
in building
permits
which will
give us
straight up
plays
in single
stocks
in the
construction
sector
and even
in the
financial
sector
as well
and all
of the
subsectors
within
the
financial
sector
so
in the
US
the sector
data
in the
ISM
what did
we actually
see there
well
it led
us
to join
the dots
between
the macro
and the
micro
so the
sector
data
allows us
to do
that
but remember
you still
have to
do
all of
the work
on the
individual
stocks
themselves
so
once
you've
identified
sector
trends
or
potential
changes
to
trend
this
doesn't
mean
abandon
the entire
trade idea
generation
process
at the
stock
level
okay
you still
have to
do the
quantitative
assessment
you still
have to
do the
qualitative
work
you still
have to
look for
catalysts
and you
still
have to
structure
and time
your
trades
as
best
possible
now
for
international
macro
driven
individual
stock
trade
ideas
in
American
depository
receipts
ADRs
we use
those
to increase
our
opportunity
set
but
we do
have to
be
very
careful
and make
sure
that when
we're
joining
the dots
between
macro
and micro
that we're
not coming
to false
conclusions
okay
so our
primary
concern
here
is that
if we
identify
strong
or weak
macro
conditions
in a
particular
geography
we need
to make
sure
that we
get
exposure
that in
a single
stock
in a
play
that's
as
accurate
possible
it's
as
representative
possible
so we
capture
the
micro
in
the
revenue
and
earnings
of
the
single
stock
that
we're
taking
a
position
in
there's
no
point
in
identifying
a
surprise
change
in
trend
or
a
macro
change
in
trend
a
particular
geography
if
the
position
that
you
end
up
with
is
either
not
directly
exposed
to
that
in
their
revenue
and
earnings
or
just
has
very
little
exposure
to
it
we
need
to
get
as
pure
play
as
possible
so
again
it
just
comes
down
to
being
organized
using
common
sense
and
joining
the
dots
properly
okay
so
we're
now
going to
move
into
the
next
part
of
the
PTM
video
series
we're
now
going to
be
looking
at
timing
your
trade
ideas
as
optimally
possible
so
the
next
two
videos
are
going
to be
split
into
two
parts
we're
going
to be
looking at
technical
analysis
and price
action
so
technical
analysis
is
primarily
concerned
with
pattern
recognition
and
price
action
is
primarily
concerned
with
momentum
indicators
and
on the
surface
it all
sounds
very
scientific
and
really
impressive
but
once you
understand
the
content
properly
and
both
its
uses
and
its
limitations
it
really
isn't
that
impressive
guys
so
let's
dive
into
it
let's
go
into
the
dark
world
of
technical
analysis
and
price
action
and
I'll
see
you
back
at
the
desk
a
little
bit
later
on